right now the best estimate of when the
Big Bang when the Big Bang occurred and
once again I don't like the term that
much because it kind of implies some
type of explosion but what it really is
is kind of an expansion of space when
it's space started to really start to
expand from a singularity but our best
estimate of when this occurred is 13.7
billion billion years ago and even
though we're used to dealing with
numbers in the billions especially when
we talk about large amounts of money and
whatnot this is an unbelievable amount
of time it seems like something that is
tractable but it really isn't and in
future videos I'm actually going to talk
about the time scale so we can really
appreciate how long or even start to
appreciate or appreciate that we can't
appreciate how long 13.7 billion years
is and I also want to want to emphasize
that this is the current best estimate
even in my lifetime even in my lifetime
that I actually knew about the Big Bang
and that I would pay attention to what
the best estimate was this this numbers
been moving around so I suspect that in
the future this number might become more
accurate or might move around some but
this is our best guess now with that
said I want to think about what this
tells us about the size of the
observable universe the observable
universe observable so if the if if all
of the expansion started 13.7 billion
years ago that 13.7 billion years ago
all of everything we know in our
three-dimensional universe was in a
single point the longest that any photon
of light could be traveling that's
reaching us right now so our eye is
right so let's say that that is my eye
right over here that's my eyelashes just
like that the longest of some photon of
light some photon of light is just
getting to my eye or maybe it's just
getting to the lens of a telescope the
longest that that could have been
traveling is 13.7 billion years so it
could be traveling could be traveling
traveling 13.7 billion years so when we
looked at when we looked at that
depiction this I think was two or three
videos ago of the observer
universe I drew it was this circle it
was this circle and when we see light
coming from these remote objects that
that light is getting to us right here
this is where we are this is where I
guess in the depiction the remote object
was but the light from that remote
object is just now getting to us and
that light took that light took 13.7
billion years to get to us 13.7 billion
billion years now what I'm going to
hesitate to do because we're talking
over such large distances in it and
we're talking on such large time scales
and time scales over which space itself
is expanding we're going to see in this
video that is you cannot say you cannot
say that this object over here this is
not necessarily this is not I'll put it
in caps this is not 13.7 billion billion
light years light-years away if we're
talking about smaller timescales or I
guess smaller distances you could say
approximately that the expansion of the
universe itself would not that make what
would not make as much of a difference
and let me let me make it even more
clear I'm talking about an object over
there but we could even talk about that
coordinate in space and that coordinate
in and I try I should say that
coordinate in space time because we're
viewing it at a certain instant as well
but that coordinate is not 13.7 billion
light years away from our current
coordinate and there's a couple of
reasons to think about it first of all
think about it that light was emitted
13.7 billion years ago when that light
was emitted we were much closer to that
coordinate this coordinate was much
closer to that where we are in the
universe right now was much closer to
that point of the universe the other
thing to think about is as this let me
let me actually draw it so let's say
that let's say that let's say that let's
go 300,000 years after the form after
after that initial of that initial
expansion of that singularity so we're
just three hundred thousand years into
the universe's history right now so this
is roughly three hundred thousand years
three hundred thousand years into the
universes a life I guess we could view
it that way
and let's say at that point well first
of all at that point you know we have
all things haven't differentiated in a
meaningful way yet right now I mean
we'll talk more a lot about this when we
talk about the cosmic microwave
background radiation but at this point
in the universe it was kind of this
almost uniform white-hot plasma of
hydrogen and then we're going to talk
about it was a meeting you know
microwave radiation and we'll talk more
about that in a future video but let's
just think about two points in this
early in this early universe so in this
early universe let's say you have that
point and let's say you have the
coordinate where we are right now you
have the coordinate where we are right
now in fact I'll I'll just make that
roughly I won't make it the center just
because I think it makes it easier to
visualize if it's not the center and
let's hit that very early stage in the
universe if you were able to just take
some rulers instantaneously and measure
that you would measure this distance you
would measure this distance to be 30
million 30 million 30 million light
years
30 million light years and let's just
say right at that point this object over
here I'll do it in magenta this object
over here emits a photon maybe in the
microwave frequency radio range and
we'll see that that was the range that
it was emitting in but it emits a photon
so right and that photon is traveling at
the speed of light it is light and so
that photon says oh you know what I only
got 30 million light years to travel
that's not too bad I'm going to get
there in 30 million years and so I'm
going to do a discrete the math is more
complicated than what I'm doing here but
I really just want to give you the idea
of what's going on here so let's just
say let's just say well you know that
photon says you're in about in about ten
million years and in roughly ten million
years I should be right about I should
be right about at that coordinate
I should be about one third of the
distance but what happens what happens
over the course of those ten million
years well over the course of those ten
million years the universe has expanded
some the universe has expanded maybe a
good deal so let me draw this expanded
universe so after ten million years the
universe
might look like this actually might even
be bigger than that let me draw it like
this after 10 million years the universe
might have expanded a good bit so this
is 10 million years into the future
still by on a cosmological timescale
still almost at the kind of the the
infancy of the universe because we're
talking about 13.7 billion years so
let's say 10 million years 10 million
years go by the universe is expanded
this coordinate where we're sitting
today at the present time is now is now
all the way over here that that
coordinate where the photon was
originally emitted is now is now going
to be sitting right over here and that
photon it said okay and after 10 million
light years I'm going to get over there
and you know I'm approximating and I'm
doing in a very discreet way but you can
I really just want to give you the idea
so that coordinate where the photon
roughly gets in 10 million light years
is about right over here the whole
universe is expanded all the coordinates
have gotten further away from each other
now what just happened here the universe
is expanded this distance that was 30
million light years now and I don't I'm
I'm just making rough numbers here I
don't know the actual numbers here now
it is actually this is really just for
the sake of sake of giving you the idea
of why well giving you the intuition of
what's going on this distance now is no
longer 30 million light years it could
be maybe it's a hundred million so this
is now a hundred million a hundred
million light years away from each other
the universe is expanding these
coordinates this the space is actually
spreading out you can imagine it's kind
of a trampoline or the surface of a
balloon getting stretched thin and so
this coordinate where the light happens
to be after ten million years it has
been traveling for ten million years but
it's gone a much larger distance it is
now it is now gone that distance now
might be on the order of maybe it's on
the order of 30 million light years and
the math isn't exact here I haven't done
the the math to figure it out but the
point here so it's done 30 million light
years and and and I want to make it
actually I shouldn't even make it
the same proportion because the distance
it's gone in the distance that it has to
go because of the stretching it's not
going to be completely linear at least
it when I'm thinking about in my head it
shouldn't be I think but I'm not going
to make a hard statement about that but
the distance that it traversed the
distance that it traversed maybe this
distance right here is now twenty
million light years 20 million light
years
even though because it got there every
time it moved some distance that the
space that it had traversed is now
stretched so even though it's traveled
even though it's traveled for ten
million years the space that it
traversed is no longer just ten million
light years it's now stretched to 20
million light years and the space that
it has left to traverse is no longer
only 20 million light years it might now
be 80 million light years it is now 80
million light years and so the you know
this this photon might be getting
frustrated there's no there's an
optimistic way of viewing it it's like
wow I was able to cover 20 million light
years in only 10 million years it looks
like I'm moving faster than the speed of
light the reality is it's not because
the space coordinates themselves are
spreading out those are getting thin so
the photon is just moving at the speed
of light but the distance that it
actually traversed in ten million years
is more than ten million light years
it's 20 million light years so you can't
just multiply a rate times time on these
cosmological scales here that's that's
especially when the coordinates
themselves
the distance coordinates are actually
semi but I think you see or maybe you
might see where this is going
now this says okay this photon says oh
well you know and in another in another
let me write this is 80 million light
years and another 40 million light years
maybe I'm going to get maybe I'm going
to get over here but the reality is over
those that next 40 million light years
sorry over over in 40 million years I
might get right over here because this
is 80 million light years but the
reality is after 40 million years so for
another 40 million years go by now of a
sudden the universe is expanded even
more the universe is expanded even more
I won't even draw the whole bubble but
the place where the photon was emitted
from might be over
year and now our current position is
over here where the light got after 10
million years where the light got after
10 million years is now over here and
now where the light is after 40 million
years after 40 million years is maybe
it's over here so it's actually so now
this distance this distance between
these two points and when we started it
was 10 million light years then it
became 20 million light years maybe now
it's maybe now it's on the order of I
don't know maybe it's a billion light
years maybe now it's a billion light
years and maybe this distance over here
and I'm just making up these numbers in
fact that's probably too big for that
point maybe this is now 100 million
light years this is now a hundred
million light years and now this
distance maybe is maybe this distance
right here is I don't know five hundred
million light years and maybe now the
total distance between the two points is
a billion light years so as you can see
the the photon might be getting
frustrated as it covers more and more
distance it looks back and says wow you
know and only 50 million years I've been
able to cover 600 million light years
that's pretty good but it's frustrated
because what it thought was it only had
to comfort 30 million years 30 million
light years in distance that keeps
stretching out because space itself is
stretching so the reality just going to
the original to the original idea this
photon this photon that is just reaching
us that's been traveling for let's say
13 let's say it's been traveling for
13.4 billion years so it's reaching us
just now so let me let me just fast
forward thirteen point four billion
years from from this point now to get to
the present day so if I draw the whole
visible universe right over here this
point right over here is going to be
where it was emitted from is right over
there we are we are sitting right over
there and actually let me make something
clear if I'm drawing the whole
observable universe the center actually
should be where we are because we can
observe an equal distance if if things
aren't really strange we can observe an
equal distance in any direction so
actually maybe we should put us
at the center so this was the entire
observable universe and the photon was
emitted from here thirteen point four
billion years ago so 300,000 years after
just that initial Big Bang and it's just
getting to us it's just getting to us
just getting to us it is true that the
photon has been traveling the photon has
been traveling for 13.7 billion years
billion years but what's kind of nutty
about it is this object since we've been
expanding away from each other this
object is now in our best estimates this
object is going to be about 46 billion
46 billion light years light-years away
from us away from us so and I want to
make it very clear this object is now 46
billion light-years away from us when we
just use light to observe it it you know
it looks like just based on lightyears
hey this trial lights been traveling
13.7 billion years to reach us that's
our only way of kind of with light to
kind of think about the distance so
maybe it's 13 points for for what I keep
changing the the decimal but thirteen
point four billion light years away but
the reality is if you had a ruler today
and you know light your rulers this
thing is now this the space here has
stretched so much that this is now 46
billion light years and and just to give
you a hint of when we talk about the
cosmic microwave background radiation
what will this point in space look like
this thing that's actually 46 billion
light years away but the photon only
took 13.7 billion years to reach us what
will this look like
well that thatfo it's going to you know
when we say look like it's based on the
photons that are reaching us right now
those photons left thirteen point four
billion years ago so those photons are
the photons being emitted from this from
this primitive structure from this
white-hot this white-hot haze of
hydrogen plasma so what we're going to
see is this white-hot haze so we're
going to see we're going to see a this
this kind of white hot plasma white-hot
undifferentiated not differentiated into
proper stable atoms much less stars and
but white-hot we're going to see this
white hot plasma the reality today is at
that point in space it's 46 billion
years from now it's probably
differentiated into into stable atoms
and stars and planets and galaxies and
frankly if that person that person if
there is a civilization there right now
and they're sitting right there if
they're observing photons being admitted
from our coordinate from our point in
space right now they're not going to see
us they're going to see us thirteen
point four billion years ago they're
going to see that the super primitive
state of our region of space when it
really was just it a white-hot plasma
and we're going to talk more about this
in the next video but think about it any
photon that's coming from that period in
time so from any direction that's been
traveling for 13.4 billion years from
any direction it's going to come from
that primitive state or it's going to it
would have been emitted when the
universe was in that primitive state
when it was just that white-hot plasma
this undifferentiated mass and hopefully
that'll give you a sense of where the
cosmic microwave background radiation
comes from